dans un état désespéré depuis dimanche
dernier marie trintignant est morte ce
matin dans une clinique de neuilly une
autopsie est en cours
l'enquète selon la justice française
sera élargie à une qualification
criminelle très nombreux hommages après
le décès de l'actrice
le chassé croisé du 1er août une
circulation en accordéon des bouchons
bien sûr ici ou là en attente de la
journée noire
annoncée pour demain par bison futé des
enfants d'une colonie de vacances dans
l'autre fauché par une voiture à la nuit
tombée hier huit ont été blessées dont
quatre grièvement
le cuisiner du centre qui était au
volant a été laissé en liberté
la situation sous contrôle sur le front
des incendies les pompiers restent
vigilants des patrouilles de
surveillance sont organisées alors que
quelques reprises ont été signalés à la
mode mais monsieur bonsoir rapatrié en
france en état de mort cérébrale marie
trintignant c'était un ce matin depuis
les hommages se succèdent l'émotion et
la tristesse dans le coeur de chacun
nous y reviendrons et d'abord les
développements judiciaires de cette
affaire qui désormais porte une
qualification criminelle
une autopsie a été demandée par la
justice française alors que vilnius
bertrand cantat soupçonné d'être à
l'origine du drame a été suspectée
hospitalisée dans un état psychologique
instable dorothée cochard mode enough
madame marie trintignant est décédé ce
matin à 10h20 des suites d'un oedème
cérébral et ce malgré la réanimation
poursuivi depuis son arrivée à la
clinique hartmann
je vous remercie
la dernière opération aura été vaine
marie trintignant rapatriés hier soir de
lituanie s'est donc éteinte après cinq
jours de coma le corps de l'actrice a
été transporté à l'institut médico légal
de paris pour y subir une autopsie
comment marie trintignant est elle morte
le chanteur bertrand cantat son
compagnon a avoué avoir giflé l'actrice
samedi soir au cours d'une dispute après
une soirée arrosée
selon lui elle aurait perdu connaissance
en tombant un accident quelque sorte une
version que récuse la famille de
l'actrice qu'on peut supposer à la
lumière des certificats médicaux établis
c'est que les traumatismes sans trop
nettement affirmée pour que ça puisse
résulter d'une chute accidentelle sur
une moquette une conviction que semblent
accréditer les dires du neurochirurgien
celui là même qui a tenté la dernière
opération pour sauver marie trintignant
il affirme que l'actrice n'avait pas
reçu une simple gifle mais plusieurs
coups tous violents
circonstance aggravante déclare la
famille bertrand cantat n'aurait pas
appelé les secours
c'est du moins ce qu'affirme et hier la
mère de l'actrice défunte 6h trop tard
il aurait fallu la mener immédiatement
bertrand cantat a été transféré ce matin
à l'hôpital pénitentiaire de vilnius
dans un état psychologique fragile
il est accusé de coups et blessures
volontaires ayant entraîné la mort et de
non assistance à personne en danger
bertrand cantat encourent 15 ans de
réclusion criminelle
on ferait de la famille trintignant mari
avait commencé à faire ses premiers pas
devant la caméra dès l'enfance une
personnalité au charme énigmatique est
la voix sombre est immédiatement
reconnaissable
une actrice et une comédienne accomplie
une femme de passion et de tumulte
jacques chirac en ce soir hommage à
celle qui servait son art avec beauté
sensibilité et intelligence
marylène bono rémy posséder pour son
dernier rôle celui de colette marie
trintignant à travailler en famille avec
sa mère réalisatrice son fils comédien
et son frère assistant réalisateur
le clan trintignant et surtout son père
jean-louis avec qui elle avait des liens
si forts
je crois que petite elle a jamais pleuré
je sais pas je me souviens pas que
qu'elle ait été un moment un problème
souci elle a été que du bonheur
deux pièces de théâtre ensemble poèmes à
lou et conversations sur un quai de gare
michel je m'appelle mais chif c'est
marrant comme un vrai que ça marrant
à 4 ans et je voulais être vétérinaire
mais sa mère lui confie un rôle dans mon
amour mon amour qui marie trintignant a
tourné une trentaine de films elle
s'impose en 1992 dans betty de claude
chabrol dans le cri de l'asseoir 1987 sa
beauté et son talent éclate elle a voulu
être comédienne pour soigner sa timidité
de jouer ça est parce que ce qu'il ya
dans le cinéma la télévision c'était
pour elle le même métier
en 99 et les victoires qui luttent pour
l'avortement c'est que les avortements
clandestins
l'utilisation des sons des aiguilles à
tricoter diverses plantes et un réel
danger pour les femmes
l'an dernier le chanteur thomas fersen
lui avait écrit une chanson paris cette
bosse très singulière qui qui m'a plu et
puis je sentais que je pouvais écrire
des histoires et surtout elle pouvait
incarner des personnages que je pouvais
d'écrire dans mes chansons
marie trintignant un destin brisé
à 41 ans la qualité de ce 1er août et
bien évidemment marquée par la vague des
grands départs le week-end sans doute le
plus chargé de l'année
ces deux mc que le chassé croisé des
vacanciers devraient provoquer de
sérieux bouchons
bison futé a classé noir toute la
journée de samedi alors à en avant goût
aujourd'hui il y avait des encombrements
sur les routes à commencer bien sûr par
la vallée du rhône une virginité mortier
qui avec jgc là un petit air d'accordéon
sur les autoroutes de la vallée du rhône
aujourd'hui pas de gros blocage mais des
à coups dans la circulation
une alternance de forts ralentissements
et de fluidité
une bonne surprise pour les
automobilistes qui s'attendaient à
rencontrer des bouchons sur les aires
d'autoroutes pas de surcharge non plus
on se repose avec le sourire pour
l'instant on a évité le pire
excellent
j'étais très étonné le tunnel de lyon
sans aucun problème pas de bouchon ap
cannes
les cards le sans problème on vient de
belgique est on roll on roll a pas de
bouchon en vient on a eu un petit
ralentissement mais c'est bien passé
là on se dépêche pas ce qu'il me voulait
m'avoir on annonce une journée noire
d'une salle opérationnelle du centre
d'information routière
si on informe le public et on gère le
trafic car même si la journée n'a pas
été noir la région rhône-alpes a connu
86 km de bouchons au plus fort de la
journée pour ce week end le plus chargé
de l'année le plan palomar a été mise en
place un plan de gestion des crises
on ouvre d hitler soin de ses
itinéraires bis soit des itinéraires
alternatifs autoroutiers qui sont
affichés sur les panneaux à messages
variables de l'autoroute
aujourd'hui une situation tendue mais
qui nécessite pas énormément de
délestage parce qu'on n'a pas de
situation de blocage à proprement dit
blé plus une circulation difficile dans
la circulation est maintenant beaucoup
plus calme mais les premiers bouchons
devraient réapparaître dès trois heures
du matin
conseils de bison futé rien ne sert de
partir trop tôt pour mieux rouler autant
partir dans l'après midi
aujourd'hui une circulation donc
partiellement fluide davantage de
ralentissement que de route totalement
saturé on voulait souvent opa sur les
grands axes routiers
mais avec modération le point julia
delage des philippines la journée était
classée rouge mais finalement sur les
routes on a eu plus de peur que de mal
au péage de la monnaie au sud de tours
même on n'avait jamais vu ça par rapport
aux autres années on n'a pas de gros
bouchons n'est donnée quant même
8 km de bouchon tout de même sur l'a10
un accident qui n'a fait aucun blessé a
bloqué la circulation pendant plusieurs
heures mais finalement pour les
vacanciers qui descendait dans le
sud-ouest la journée s'est plutôt bien
passé on est en plein dedans on a été
coincé une heure une heure et demie ont
fait qu'un bébé c'est pas évident pour
faire 250 max et moi c'est bon c'est
l'essentiel
moins chanceux d'autres ont dû oublier
la vitesse même sont les camions
interdite à la circulation on a compté
jusqu'à 250 km de bouchons et j'en ai
plus engorgées la traditionnelle vallée
du rhône et l'ile-de-france le
languedoc-roussillon est évidemment
l'accès aux stations balnéaires un bilan
positif donc mais automobilistes
n'oubliez pas pour ce week-end le plus
chargé de l'année
le ministère des transports a prévu un
dispositif policier expulsion directe de
rené sous peu nous vous retrouverons
album nicosie pour un poids de la
circulation lors en cette fin de soirée
et la nuit prochaine de sérieuses
difficultés devraient apparaître bien
avant l'aube
c'est tout à fait probable béatrice ce
week-end est un week-end particulier
dans l'année puisque on le sait les
automobilistes profitent de la nuit pour
partir alors les premiers embouteillages
sont prévues dès 6 heures du matin sur
un axe qui partirait du nord-est et qui
ré vers la méditerranée notamment à
travers la vallée du rhône alors la
sécurité routière vous conseille si vous
comptiez partait ça cette nuit
évidemment de prévoir des plages de
repos parce que l'endormissement est
évidemment plus facile la nuit alors
évidemment de massat mérite d'être
souligné c'est la seule journée noire de
l'année sur l'ensemble de la france
c'est même pour ça que bison futé a été
créé en 1975 pour ce premier week end
d'août avec un chassé-croisé important
ce sera même une journée noire vous
l'avez dit sur l'ensemble territoire ce
qui veut dire que bien les les bouchons
se compteront par centaines de
kilomètres l'an dernier c'était 800 km
alors il n'y a pas de bon moment pour
partir demain autant vous le dire tout
de suite il ya un très mauvais moment
c'est entre 10 heures et 16 heures donc
dans la mesure du possible évitez 10h
16h partait plutôt dimanche ou encore
mieux lundi lundi est une journée verte
selon bison futé
un dernier mot en région parisienne
compte tenu de la pollution est bien la
préfecture de police vient de nous
prévenir
la vitesse sur autoroute comme sur route
sera limité de 20 km heure ce qui veut
dire pas plus de 110 demain sur les
autoroutes
merci albert nicosie vous l'aurez sans
doute constaté les prévisions de bison
futé ces derniers mois semble souvent
plus pessimiste que la réalité selon
quels critères bison futé lance-t-il ces
avertissements et si le système était
aujourd'hui difficilement quantifiable
depuis l'étalement des vacances et les
35 heures tentative d'explication avec
laurence de l'heure et olivier robert
hill 100 km de bouchons entre paris et
l'espagne c'était le 2 août 1975 un an
plus tard un indien symbole de la
débrouillardise vient au secours des
vacanciers en détresse bison futé est né
mais qui se cache derrière ces longues
plumes 1 voici l'endroit où est planté
son tipi à l'intérieur du centre
national d'information routière de
prévisionnistes dans leurs ordinateurs
dix ans de données sur le trafic et les
bouchons alimenté par une centaine de
stations de comptage
un logiciel permet de comparer la
circulation d'un jour données sur
plusieurs années différentes et
d'évaluer un an à l'avance les
embouteillages des vacances un
calendrier jugé plutôt fiable par les
automobilistes
est ce que vous pensez des prévisions de
bison futé en général sont bonnes jamais
il se trompe en disant qu'ils vont
devenir de plus en plus c'est que le
météo de la plate forme phare voir le
bon temps les sioux sans venir les
hordes de voitures dans 80% des cas mais
il a parfois eu oreilles sourdes ont
même très gros échec qu'il ya deux étés
c'était l'été 2001 on attendait du
orange ou du rouge confirmerait du rhône
et pourtant on a eu des journées noires
pratiquement en fait la très belle qu'un
deuxième quinzaine du mois d'août a été
mise à profit par beaucoup de vacanciers
pour prendre une semaine de vacances aux
des journées alors qu'on n'avait pas du
tout prévu on pensait qu'on se fait
plutôt dans une configuration de retour
ces journées là le problème depuis 15
ans le logiciel de bison futé n'a pas
évolué mais les français si on était sur
un modèle de vacances le mois entier
un seul endroit et une seule fois donc
une seule fois dans
dans l'année maintenant c'est plus
souvent moins longtemps et plus
diversifiée une enquête sur les
comportements touristiques des français
est envisagée bison futé a désormais
besoin d'un bon relookages du côté des
gars maintenant la sncf attend plus de 3
millions de voyageurs jusqu'à dimanche
l'affluence des grands jours notamment
dans les gares parisiennes qui
absorberont elle seule la moitié des
départs et des arrivées en nuances sur
les quais de la gare de lyon vincent
fourcade je sais boulesteix difficile à
croire mais pour certains voyageurs le
meilleur moment les vacances c'est bien
le retour à la maison
j'ai vu comment une semaine donc je suis
content de les récupérer
sur les quais de gare un 1er août
l'heure est aux retrouvailles aux
séparations monsieur ou madame partir et
sait déjà quoi faire sitôt rentré chez
lui cet effet de la maison cet effet de
la nettoyer avant d'évoquer la lessive
bonnes vacances
toutes les trois minutes un nouveau
départ en gare de lyon est à chaque fois
l'ultime conseil de ceux qui restent à
quai en disant qu'il fallait que mon
fils soit sage parce que les gens
regardent d'une demande
amélie et agen tu vas aller en prison
la grande transhumance estivale a donc
commencé 3 million de voyageurs attendus
pour le grand chassé croisé de l'été la
moitié rien que dans les gares
parisiennes où se croiseront quelques
2300 train au niveau ramon a quasiment
95% de notre parc qui est dehors
mais mes collègues de l'atelier nous
disent qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui ils ont
plus une rame en atelier tout où
circulent les trains sur les rails les
gilets rouges et les agents d'ambiance
dans les gares plus de 800 d'entre eux
ont été déployés pour rendre le voyage
plus sympathique
je ne mens pas je ferai tout pour que
tout le monde soit heureux même quand il
ya des grèves même quand il pleut même
pouvoir ce cousin de garde
un vendredi aux allures de répétition
générale car la plus grosse journée du
rail de l'année commencera demain matin
pour jeunes la bretagne les alpes où la
méditerranée des centaines de tgv seront
à quai c'est trois jours pour acheminer
les vacanciers et pour parer à tout
éventuel accident les trains grande
vitesse ont été soigneusement contrôlé
comme le montre ce reportage de julien
benedetto et chaussées playtex les tgv
aussi ont leur garage dans ce
gigantesque atelier de villeneuve saint
georges
ils sont bichonnés chacun leur tour une
sorte de contrôle technique pour trains
fin dispensable avant le grand chassé
croisé de ce week-end nous avons une
flotte de 150 que je veux nous comptons
donc nous allons réussir à mettre en
oeuvre 92% de ce parc de te je veux
quasiment tous les trains sur les rails
du jamais vu à la sncm depuis une
semaine les 600 techniciens du site de
maintenance sont donc mobilisés il
travaille sept jours sur sept en trois
huit
il ya toujours des choses des impacts
sur la route et d usure anormale
on a tous le trouve toujours quelque
chose c'est quand même une grande
responsabilité de vérifier ça bah ouais
c'est par rapport à la sécurité du
passager les systèmes de climatisation
très sollicité cet été on s'était
particulièrement contrôlés à l'intérieur
des rames tous les compartiments sont
nettoyés une inspection minutieuse qui
apporte parfois son lot de surprises par
rapport à cette les lacérations bon nous
on change on change la 6e du coût du
vandalisme
sur les 3 millions de passagers ce week
end près de la moitié prendra place dans
les tous derniers tgv duplex fraîchement
livré à la sncf capable de transporter
30 % de voyageurs en plus ses trains ice
age 56 au total sont prêts à avaler les
kilomètres
la gare de lyon nous retrouvons luxe
basée à la sncf après les grands moyens
pour ce chassé croisé du 1er août
oui effectivement il s'agit vraiment du
week-end le plus chargé dans les gares
parisiennes puisque trois millions de
voyageurs ont donc choisi de prendre le
train pour leurs déplacements dont un
million et demi vers les seules gares
parisiennes
en fait la plus fréquente est bien sûr
celle ci la gare de lyon avec 720 un tgv
transportant 370 mille voyageurs vers
les alpes et la méditerranée
en fait il ya tout juste trois quarts
d'heure une panne électrique est
intervenu sur des caténaires résultat
quatre voix sur 22 se trouve
actuellement bloqué un train n'a pas pu
prendre le départ un train pour lyon les
voyageurs ont donc été transféré vers le
train suivant la sncf promet de rétablir
le courant sur ces voies dans la soirée
les autres trains eux 10 1 partent
normalement et surtout qu'en plus des
rames supplémentaires mis en place la
sncf a livré 53 rames de tgv duplex
comme on vient de le voir c'est à dire
ddd train à double étage qui ont permis
d'accroître le nombre de places
d'environ 30% alors le flux des gros
départs devraient durer encore pendant
une heure ou deux pour reprendre de plus
belle dès demain samedi
merci ligue d'aziza sur le front des
incendies maintenant l'extrême vigilance
demeure la situation était tellement
sous contrôle dans le sud-est de la
france reste des colonnes de pompiers
sur le qui vive le feu sous étroite
surveillance comme dans le var à la mode
tout plusieurs reprises ont été
enregistrées cet après midi reportage
caroline gauthier roma potok
au fond du vallon une fumée s'élève une
nouvelle repris y est c'est la septième
cet après-midi pour éteindre les flammes
il faut aller les chercher 300 mètres en
contrebas au milieu des broussailles une
végétation très dense est hostile aux
verts qui sont en train de brûler si on
les traite pas qu'est ce qui va se
passer automatiquement ça va reprendre
un petit peu d'ampleur un sous l'effet
du vent et ça va tout remettre le feu
dans le vallon et boulez qui n'a pas
volé quoi c'est un travail dur et
harassant et c'est pas quelque chose de
gratifiant mais pour le faire hein voilà
maintenant les tronçonneuses tous les
dieux
et enfin le chemin voilà parce que les
banquiers en patron sonos des petites
machette alors bon en gagnent du temps
et pour appuyer les hommes au sol les
traqueurs sont cette fois encore les
bienvenus il faut protéger ce qui reste
de verdure dans ce massif éteindre
toutes les fibres hall et la tâche
s'annonce bien longue a alors déroulé au
les tuyaux et on y va au contact des
voyageurs prendront plusieurs jours
qu'ils sont complètement éteint les
jours actuellement il est fixé ce qui
veut dire qu'il n'évolue plus il est
sous contrôle
en revanche il n'est pas toujours pas
éteint compte tenu que l'on n'est pas
certain de ne pas avoir demain encore
des reprises des températures
caniculaires sont annoncés ce week end
pas question donc de lever le dispositif
pour l'instant oui à présent comment les
vacanciers réagissent ces paysages de
désolation qui devait être pour certains
le cadre choisi pour leur séjour les
professionnels du tourisme craignait de
nombreuses annulations notamment dans
les campings
pour l'heure difficile de faire un bilan
mais pour les mordus de la plage et du
soleil
on reste sur place coûte que coûte comme
aux issambres reportage véronique gens
et raymond châtelard
le vallon de la gaillarde calcinés et un
îlot de verdure
le feu s'est arrêté aux portes du
camping des issambres
il a bien fallu évacuer pour une nuit
mais les habitudes ont vite repris le
dessus
ça fait mal au coeur de voir doubler
comme ça parce que ça nous gâcher les
vacances n'ont pas lu tout ce qu'ils ont
eu peur des incendies ont en réalité
déjà quitté la côte pour les autres pas
question de se laisser miner le moral le
centre d'intérêt c'est la plage qui est
à proximité tout proche
autrefois que nos enfants maintenant que
sans les enfants petits aux plus grands
mais c'est vraiment la mer et le soleil
qui nous attire et la plage elle ne
désemplit pas difficile de mettre un
pied devant l'autre cet après midi sans
piétiner une serviette
pourtant dans les jours qui viennent les
aoûtiens sont attendus en nombre et les
professionnels du tourisme sont inquiets
je pense qu'ils auront une franche et
intel qui devait venir en août qui ne
viendra pas vu les images
catastrophiques qu'on a vu donc il y
aura une diminution de clientèle c'est
simple d'ores et déjà le camping
enregistré des annulations se sont
finalement les vacanciers qui ont vécu
les incendies de loin qui prennent peur
pour ceux qui étaient là c'est la
fatalité
le jeu
le mistral le mistral le soleil sous le
soleil et il assure déjà qu'ils
reviendront l'année prochaine
la politique de prévention sérieusement
mise à mal ces derniers jours la
construction dans des zones à risque d'
incendies auraient dû être limité même
interdite or le ministère de l'ecologie
affirme ce soir qu'aucune commune dans
le var n'avait utilisé ce dispositif
en revanche du côté de marseille la
leçon a été comprise depuis les grands
feux de 1997
reportage yannick aroussi benoît jour
dans la vue est superbe mais elle devra
se mériter le chemin d'accès à la maison
fera 5 m de large pour permettre le
passage des engins de pompiers
le fourneau piscine
l'usap immolé par le feu le local
technique qui allume encore la roma
système
mais bon
hopper est en partie arrière de la
maison d'ailleurs à en trouver aussi de
lancer sans avenir
christophe est architecte pour obtenir
son permis de construire en limite de la
zone boisée
il a dû mettre le paquet question
sécurité le système de brumisateurs qui
protégera l'arrière du terrain va coûter
2300 euros
la saloperie de la sécurité donc en
sentant protégées
il ya aucun problème de ce côté là bien
sûr il y à marseille 120 km de zones
périurbaines au contact des forêts alors
depuis plus d'un an chaque permis de
construire est examiné par un comité
risque urbanisme il peut être refusée ou
accordée sous réserve d'aménagement
nous avons estimé qu'il fallait faire
plus que la réglementation pour éviter
bien entendu des catastrophes tels qu'on
peut voir partout mais bien entendu il
faut rester très humble par rapport à
tout ça c'est un plus mais quand notre
part malheureusement il part pour éviter
la catastrophe les matériaux
inflammables comme le pvc sont proscrits
les citernes de gaz interdite et l'accès
des pompiers doit être facilitée l'idée
étant de rendre les maisons entre
guillemets un combustible pour qu'on
puisse plus facilement se projeter dans
la protection du massif et que les
occupants soient en sécurité dans leurs
maisons
la règle principale reste le
débroussaillement autour des maisons
c'est d'ailleurs la seule obligation
légale en la matière et puis ce soir
jean pierre raffarin annonce des aides
d'urgence pour les personnes nées les
entreprises il annonce également des
aides exceptionnelles pour les services
d'incendié et de secours
partons à présent pour la gironde où la
situation demeure extrêmement
préoccupante en raison de la sécheresse
dans cette région la prévention est
devenu capital quotidiennement des
équipes surveillent la forêt de gascogne
la plus grande forêt d'europe
éric perrin dubaï en matière de
prévention des risques d'incendié rien
ne vous la présence sur le terrain les
extrémités des fougères en cause tous
les matins aux premières heures chaque
caserne de gironde envoie des hommes en
visite d'inspection premier objectif
constater les niveaux des points d'eau
il est bon les sommiers grain car depuis
trois mois la pluviométrie est très
inférieur à la normale qui est en
dessous du niveau normal
mais ces points d'eau sont inspectés
aussi et surtout parce qu'ils peuvent se
révéler essentiel en cas d'incendié
points d'eau servent à l'alimentation
des engins suivant le concerne le
secteur concerné c'est à dire qu'on les
met judicieusement pour ne pas avoir à
les chercher l'eau à des kilomètres
le manque d'eau et la canicule ont bien
sûr des répercussions sur la végétation
et attention aux apparences trompeuses
comme vous pouvez le constater la
végétation supérieur est encore verte
mais on peut observer que en dessous les
anciennes fougères sèches
tous les comptes rendus de visites de
surveillance sont centralisées ici au
poste de commandement ils servent à
déterminer l'échec du risque en raison
de l'absence de vent cette journée
classée risque au courant le plus faible
mais on pourrait très vite basculer au
risque sévère voire extrême le
dispositif montre à l'heure en puissance
avant ce qu'on appelle partout en france
des deep des détachements d'intervention
préventive que l'on met à des points
stratégiques en fonction des relevés du
matin en fonction des risques dans
différentes zones grâce aux 22 pylône de
gironde la forêt qui couvre à elle seule
la moitié du département est sous
surveillance permanent à 45 mètres de
haut l'observateur peut détecter toute
fumée suspecte et mieux vaut avoir
l'oeil avisé à la couleur on peut savoir
si ces départs de feu ou en tracteur
agricole où un feu de voiture avec la
météo caniculaire annoncé les pompiers
du sud ouest savent qu'ils vont devoir
plus que jamais être vigilant meilleurs
en europe de très gros feux de forêt
tous le centre du portugal
attisés par des vents violents les
pompiers luttent contre ces gros
incendie qui ravage la région depuis
près d'une semaine
la piste criminelle semble évidente de
personnes sont mortes carbonisées
je vous le disais en petit train groupe
d'enfants appartenant à une colonie de
vacances a été fauché hier soir par une
voiture près de narbonne
on ignore précisément les circonstances
du drame le cuisinier du centre qui
était au volant avec un alcootest
négatif vitesse excessive imprudence les
enfants qui avaient quitté à la nuit
tombée la colonie ont été blessés pour
la moitié dont quatre grièvement
aurélia guillemat france à revoir les
traces de pneus sont encore visibles il
est 22 heures hier soir sur ce chemin
communal 16 enfants d'une colonie de
vacances toutes proches entame une
promenade avec leurs accompagnateurs
lorsque à bord d'une courbe le cuisinier
de l'établissement qui vient de quitter
son travail fauche 12 d'entre eux
surpris par la présence donc de
marcheurs
à proximité de la fosse et il a freiné
de manière énergique avec le véhicule
est parti en travers et approché d'elle
les promeneurs bilan huit blessés dont
quatre graves deux enfants souffrent de
fractures deux autres de traumatismes
crâniens
le conducteur qui n'était pas en état
d'ivresse roule est il trop vite
le groupe était il suffisamment visibles
les gendarmes s'interrogent l'idéal
c'est d'être vu donc hors de portée des
chasubles réfléchissantes soit au
minimum d'avoir en fait une lampe torche
en tête de colonne une lampe torche
enchaîne colonne et une lampe côté
circulation est ici est-ce que c'était
le temps la pièce va nous permettre de
les terminer mais à l'heure actuelle
nous n'avons aucune certitude le dessus
ce soir sur 12 enfants blessés huit sont
encore en observation les autres ont été
prises en charge par une cellule
psychologique
il devrait rapidement regagner leur
domicile l'actualité internationale
et voici un nouveau message attribué à
saddam hussein il s'agit du cinquième
depuis le début du mois l'ancien
dictateur toujours très activement
recherché par les troupes américaines
sur le terrain la guérilla continue et
frédéric retard en plein territoire
sunnite
la résistance a frappé nous sommes à 200
km de bagdad
hier soir une explosion retentit dans le
désert l'oléoduc qui relie les champs
pétrolifères de kirkouk à la raffinerie
de baïji bien être sa beauté cet
incident va compliquer la production et
ralentir les exportations de pétrole
un signal fort émis par les partisans de
saddam hussein alors même que le
président déchu vient d'envoyer un
nouveau message radio c'est le sixième
du genre
elham infuser par al-jazira la joie
attribué à saddam demande au peuple
irakien de protéger les biens et de
résister à l'occupant si saddam hussein
demeure toujours introuvable
ses deux filles ont réapparu elle avait
quitté l'irak pour la syrie deux
semaines après la chute de leur
dictateur de père ragga derana ainsi que
leurs neuf enfants ont été accueillis
par la jordanie
dans une interview à la chaîne
al-arabiya la fille aînée rakkad déplore
que son père était trahi par ceux en qui
ils avaient le plus confiance notamment
au moment de la bataille de bagdad une
fille peu rancunière en 96 son mari et
celui de sa soeur avaient été liquidés
par l'entourage de leur père au motif de
trahison l'exil pour les femmes la mort
pour les gars ont livrés en pâture aux
américains par cet homme le même qui
leur avait offert l'hospitalité dans
quelques jours il empochera un chèque de
30 millions de dollars
la récompense la plus élevée jamais
offerte par le gouvernement américain en
turquie attentat près du ministère de la
justice en car à dix sept policiers ont
été blessés dont deux grièvement il
explosif était caché dans un sac
l'attentât a été revendiqué par un petit
groupe clandestin d'extrême gauche
revenons à présent sur la mort tragique
de marie trintignant victimes probables
de la violence de son compagnon au delà
de ce drame
nous avons choisi d'évoquer la
maltraitance que subissent de nombreuses
femmes chaque année en france
les chiffres donnent le vertige se fit
rodier a nié tri boire jusqu'à
l'accouchement
à l'autre bout du fil une jeune femme
anonyme
elle a enfin osé franchir le pas
décroché son téléphone pour parler de ce
qu'elle endure depuis
une évidence et ça s'installe et y at-il
entre rousset et lens sont répétés
centre et chaque année elles sont de
plus en plus nombreuses à briser la loi
du silence
quinze mille appels enregistrés l'an
dernier mais tout reste à faire
selon une enquête un million et demi de
femmes ont été confrontés un jour à une
situation de violence verbale physique
ou sexuelle soit une femme sur dix
victimes de violences conjugales depuis
20 ans toutes les campagnes de
sensibilisation sont destinés aux femmes
aujourd'hui les associations vont plus
loin elle cherche à comprendre ce qui
pousse un conjoint devenir violent
qu'est ce qui fait que chez certains
hommes évidemment heureusement ça ne
s'est pas tous les hommes il faut
surtout pas généraliser que certains en
arrivent aux extrémités à ses extrémités
pour maintenir le contrôle sur une autre
personne et contrairement à ce que l'on
pense la plupart des hommes violents
n'ont pas besoin d'alcool pour passer à
l'acte en france chaque mois au moins
six femmes meurent des suites de
violences infligées par leurs compagnons
à toulouse patrice alègre était entendu
une nouvelle fois aujourd'hui par le
juge d'instruction une nouvelle fois il
a nié les meurtres de la prostituée line
galbardi en 92 et du travesti claude
martinez
l'audition a duré un peu plus de deux
heures josé bové pourrait sortir de
prison plus tard demain en début d'après
midi si le parquet ne fait pas appel
josé bové pourrait finir d'exécuter sa
peine dans un chantier extérieur il
s'agirait d'une ferme du darak selon la
décision de la juge d'application des
peines et puis on apprend à l'instant
qu'un attentat a eu lieu en corse
ajaccio contre un crédit agricole de
gros dégâts mais pas de victime le
tourisme sur le continent connaît un
début de saison médiocre la
fréquentation hôtelière a baissé de 20 %
moyenne en juillet les professionnels
comptent donc plus que jamais sur le
mois d'août apeas ap avalasse les halls
lamberton édité le dic
palavas c'est la station préférée des
belges et didier est le roi de la moule
frites résultat ici on le considère
comme le baromètre de la saison
touristique
il paraît que rien qu'en voyant sa tête
on sait si l'année est bonne pour actifs
non je parle à peut-être ça va bien ça
se passe pas trop mal le début de du
mois de juillet a été plus a été un peu
calme comme chaque année puis bon là on
monte en puissance a maintenant jusqu'au
15 août à quelques mètres de là dans ce
camping
l'humeur est moins joyeuse ici on
pensait que la marée noire du prestige
amènerait des touristes qui d'ordinaire
vont sur la côte atlantique
ça n'a pas été le cas pire les quinze
premiers jours de juillet ont été plus
mauvais que l'an dernier avec une baisse
de 30 % de la fréquentation est passée
de 6 on n'a pas eu grand monde raconte
essentiellement son clientèle
hollandaise et ils ont reculé leurs
vacances cette année
et en fin de compte ils sont arrivés
beaucoup plus tard quasiment en même
temps que les français
à l'office de tourisme de palavas les
flots on estime qu'au final juillet sera
ni pire ni meilleur que les années
précédentes et on rappelle que grâce aux
ponts du mois de mai et au soleil de
juin
l'avant saison a été excellente
cependant les touristes restent toujours
près de leurs sous les vacances se sont
de plus en plus courtes maximum quinze
jours et plus personne ne se trompe dans
la conversion en euros
je pense que la première année passage à
l'euro les gens une partie attention ils
ont tiré sur le bas de laine maintenant
bas de laine étant épuisés ils font
attention il s'en rend compte et on
arrive à savoir compter 1 euros menant
pour août palavas affiche d'ores et déjà
complet
d'autant que de nombreux touristes fut
la côte d'azur à cause des incendies à
la recherche de rivages méditerranéens
pour l'instant protégé les traditionnels
hausse et baisse du 1er août à compter
de ce jour en ile-de-france la carte
orange augmente de 4 94%
le carnet de 10 tickets de 4 10% quant
au livre et à sa rémunération baisse de
3 à 2 25 % soit une baisse de 0,75 un
arrêt préfectoral et vient de classer la
ville de paris zones infestées par les
termites ou susceptibles de l'être à
court terme car les 20 arrondissements
sont déjà touchés par cet insecte en cas
de vente
les propriétaires de la capitale devant
présenter un état parasitaire de moins
de 3 mois clé milliard alexandre renard
il faut tâter scruter les boiseries pour
débusquer le termite un ennemi sournois
rongeurs de bois qui se développe avant
tout dans un environnement humide donc
s'attaque d'abord par le souffle ça
revient ensuite sa route ça cherche tout
ce qui à base de cellulose donc bois
papier carton en fait ça au monde pour
finalement arriver à la charpente mais
ça peut se propager par la mitoyenneté
par un bâtiment voisin qui est l'attaqué
même dans la case de cet immeuble du 6e
arrondissement
bertrand frédéric n'a pas trouvé de
termites pourtant ces insectes ont déjà
investi nos murs la préfecture a donc là
c'est l'ensemble de la capitale comme
zone à risque six arrondissements sont
concernés et les plus touchés sont le
cinquième le 6e ou encore le 17e ces
spécialistes espèrent avoir une idée
plus précise des zones infestées
dans le cadre de la vente d'un bien un
diagnostic préalable devra être établi
trois mois avant la
on ne sait pas si dans retrouvera dans
5% des ventes 10% ou 20%
donc c'est un dispositif qui va monter
en puissance petit à petit en fonction
des constats qu'on aura fait par rapport
aux états que nous recevrons et si un
propriétaire détecte des termites chez
lui la loi prévoit une déclaration en
mairie et une obligation de traitement
car mieux vaut prévenir que guérir un
traitement anti termites coûte environ
5000 euros alors qu'un diagnostic coûte
25 fois moins cher le premier robot
burqa autonomes vient d'être construit
en angleterre long de deux mètres il
nagera au milieu d'eux de véritables
squale permettant aux scientifiques
d'étudier l'intelligence et le
comportement des requins
isabelle qatar cherchez l'erreur
un autre lui au pays du silence de m de
long de câbles de capteurs avec son
allure il trompe bien son nom c'est un
vrai maintenant il y en a 2 devrait les
autres requins ne sont pas dupes
encore qu il le regarde comme une
curiosité ils le voient ils savent qu'il
est là ils sont un peu méfiant vis-à-vis
de lui je ne l'attaquent pas mais ils
n'ont pas non plus une attitude est
particulièrement amicale avec lui le
requin est un robot une copie presque
parfaite d'un requin gris du pacifique
l'assistant idéal pour les scientifiques
l'un des mythes les plus répandus autour
des requins c'était considéré comme de
froid de machines à tuer ce qui traverse
les océans en attente vient de jambes à
mordre
eh bien c'est faux ils sont beaucoup
plus compliqué que cela leur
comportement leur manière de communiquer
et de s'entraider seront étudiées à la
loupe pendant trois ans dans cet
aquarium grâce à un espion venu de la
terre football alors que le championnat
de l1 reprend ce soir près de 170
footballeurs professionnels n'ont
toujours pas de club depuis trois ans le
chômage des joueurs n'a cessé
d'augmenter
30% de hausse par rapport au lendemain
de la coupe du monde de 98
ces footballeurs payent la crise
économique que traverse les clubs
français un morrow en blanc l'équipe des
chômeurs en face celle de laval
ces footballeurs sans contrat en 90
minutes pour séduire plus qu'un match
c'est un marché au milieu des
spectateurs des recruteurs sont venus
chercher la bonne affaire pour leur club
possible un peu plus on discute avec
tout le monde la mentalité tout est bon
c'est on voit aussi les joueurs concon
vraiment envie parce que bon le fpc
c'est ce sont des joueurs qui sont au
chômage donc il faut qu'il veut et qui
démontre vraiment l' envie de sortir de
ce chemin à 28 ans christophe l'euro est
l'un de ces chômeurs à clairefontaine il
participe à un stage organisé
spécialement pour les joueurs sans
contrat il dit un jour son curriculum
vitae
un cv ou les buts marqués ont plus
d'importance que les diplômes scolaires
par le métier qu'elle complètement à
part donc c'est bien d'avoir
d'avoir un petit peu un répertoire de
savoir le nom de masse qu'on a fait le
nombre de but qu'on a pu marquer les
sélections et tout ça peut ça fait
intéressant ils sont 57 agir à se serrer
les coudes
en attendant le coup de fil salvateur
les entraîneurs aussi sont au chômage
qu'il se rassure avant de diriger
l'équipe de france aimé jacquet et
jacques santini se sont retrouvés eux
aussi quelques mois sans emploi -
personnellement ça me pose aucun
problème puisque c'est c'est ma volonté
et puis même sens sans penser on va se
retrouver à la tête de l'équipe de
france déjà si on retrouve un club ce
sera très bien au milieu de ses joueurs
anonymes une ancienne star du football
français
reynald pedros ou l'itinéraire d'un
enfant gâcher 25 sélections chez les
bleus un titre de champion de france
avec nantes de blessures en malchance il
est aujourd'hui sans équipe et n'épargne
pas les dirigeants des clubs français
je comprends pas pourquoi il ya des
clubs qui vont encore chercher des
joueurs à l'étranger qui leur coûte une
fortune et qui vécut au bout de quelques
mois ce qui leur serviront à rien quoi
donc ils viennent ici voir jouer les
joueurs je crois qu'il ya de la qualité
pedro comme les autres espèrent signer
un contrat dans les jours à venir
l'an dernier près de la moitié des
stagiaires ont retrouvé un club les
festivals de l'été dans l'église romane
de conques au coeur du rouergue on y
joue l'un des tubes du moyen-âge
l'histoire de robin et de marion oeuvres
datant de là l'un des plus grands
trouvèrent du xiiie siècle
bertrand renard marie pierre cassignard
sous les voûtes de cook
ce sont des bergers d'il ya 700 ans qui
nous conte leur aventure l'histoire au
quotidien duo trouvèrent adam de la
halle un mélange savant de chant et de
théâtre
moi je noue dans une langue qui fut la
nôtre celle de nos ancêtres
c'était la première fois que on faisait
un texte en français alors que tout le
tout ce qui était texte dramatique était
extrait de la bible donc donné en latin
donc robin le berger marion la bergère
mais le chevalier aubert veut marion la
bergère fait confiance aux bergère pour
repousser les perdrais et à marion la
fière pour récupérer son berger
soudain des harmonies arabisante adam de
la halle à côtoyer l'espagne musulmane
son raffinement musicale
voilà le dies avec moi et venaient sans
compter en prêtaient austère des
cathédrales le sens de la pantomime du
jeu outré robin et marion étaient des
personnages aussi connu en leur temps
que plus tard roméo juliette
mais après sept cents ans la douleur
d'un amant et me petits et grands
autant
ainsi se termine ce journal dans un
instant la météo nathalie rihouet plus
le poids ruth genner pascal 20h55 soirée
polar avec la clim avocat 6,035 le
dernier journal alexandre kara frotte à
moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
de madrid dès 13 heures je vous remercie
de votre attention
excellent le pen soirée sur france 2